- oh okay now excuse day there's one
more case there's one more case I've got
obtuse versus acute we're satisfied with
that I've got a bigger cute and a little
cute I'm okay with that there's one
other case I need to worry about where
else could I put zip that might give me
a different kind of case yeah down here
right so let's think about this one I
need one last cold
where's my argument going to big this is
going to be now this is tricky
right because arguments are tricking
arguments are like they're not unique
remember that's why we talk about a
principle argument so if I draw this
line here's one of them that's the idea
of measure for line and then I've got
this line over here I've got two ways
that I can write this I'm oh I could
draw this on you right I can either have
the reflex like soon or I could take the
principle argument which will be
negative like so there's a booth fired
right okay now again I'm gonna ask the
question which one is bigger now we can
think about this in two ways let's think
about it
for each case based on which angle you
take okay you rather have a reflex angle
take away an obtuse angle reflex take
away obtuse which one's going to be
bigger
clearly the reflex angle is bigger like
by definition reflexes above play and
you to say goes below punt you're okay
with that so that's all right what if I
take the other side this is a negative
angle I'm going to get the same answer
why is that what's the difference
between reflex angle here and negative
of to single here what's the difference
okay so the difference the difference
between these two angles is two pi
radians
do you agree with that like otherwise
I'm not going to get the actual same
argument but if I have excuse me an
angle that is like let's actually put a
number on this Joey pie is like 3.14
okay
so a reflex angle that would that looks
like that my piece of there a 3.5 you
came that was gonna make that three
point five radians that's a reflex angle
okay well what be the corresponding
negative obtuse angle that would give me
the same thing
negative we remember they're dipping
they're off by two pi if you remember
that you're a fighter two pi two pi is
about six point six to eight let's call
it six point three so that means this is
going to be something like do it like
I'm just approximating yeah okay now
think about this right this is so
negative remember it's this angle
takeaway there or not the other way
around right because subtraction is not
commutative
right this angle is so negative that
when you subtract this one you're going
to whip around and be this minus 2 pi do
you agree with that like it's a super
negative angle take away another obtuse
angle right so it's gonna be really
really negative it's gonna be so
negative you're gonna blow past minus
three point one four okay so therefore
you come back round and you'll end up
with PI over four so it works every case
we can come up with it works okay but
let's think about what happens if you
tried the other arc this other major
I've down the bottom right so if I draw
it like so pick a point for me right
let's pick an easy one like here let's
call this Z instead if I've got this
angle and this angle right where are the
arguments on visually so here is here is
our you've said take away clippers 2i is
that one and then here is the other one
now when you subtract this one take away
this what's gonna happen
look you've got an obtuse angle that's
negative and acute angle that's also
negative right you're not going to get
pilot four-eyes
right you're gonna get an another
negative obtuse angle okay so all of the
cases down here they don't work you can
try them out you do case by case when
you subtract you will not get plan for
in fact you'll get minus particles okay
think so if that's the case if that's
the angle I'm actually gonna get how
would I change the equation in like the
very first thing I wrote if you wanted
me to draw this bottom up how would I
change it if I if I wanted both Alex I
have an absolute value if you had a
picture for pain okay but if I just want
the bottom arc by if I just want the
bottom ah I want to be minus PI in for
its peak aw quit so let me just write
with the minus sign on the other side so
you kind of compare it with the -
something's inside like this it'll flip
around these two arguments do you agree
with that do you see I've just popped
the minus sign over here which would in
turn me I just take the reciprocal right
I'm subtracting them in a different
order and that will give me the bottom
ah
does that make sense okay so like I said
you can't work out the equation this
just yet but that's alright you know
enough to draw this view and you can
make it so that that's approximately
plan for you know you're gonna get a
bigger and the smaller the angle is do
you remember when I asked you to get a
really small angle I should give me like
10 degrees or something like that which
is PI on where you guys can tell me what
10 degrees is its pilot 8 right you get
this enormous surface here right so the
smaller this angle is the bigger your
arc will be okay
so it's gonna be this one here
let's give me another day the reason why
I know so you compare it to this one be
a parent to that one yep so the reason I
know is the point I just said right if
there's a small angle in here this is a
clinic I'm gonna have a big arc it's
gonna try the big arc
okay and the reason why is because the
smaller the angle is like the further
you have to stand away in order for
these to be close to each other in order
for there to be a small difference okay
if I did want this right now okay to the
Arts I promise I won't or anymore I'm
not gonna change that
how am I going to change Ukraine little
luggage I need a big angle don't I
right in fact for this one come on think
about it think about every one several
properties can you take advantage of
it's gonna be three point four do you
know why three five because because all
right he is he is one angle that was
plans for if I want this angle here well
then the opposite angles in the cyclic
quadrilateral which are supplementary
right so this angle Plus this angle
should be PI if that's prime for then
this is gonna be three platform okay